Джанан Чошкун під час сніданку дивиться,
чи не побільшає в неї роботи.
30-річна репортерка Cumhuriyet
в судах останніми роками повідомляє
про процеси над колегами.
Тут я переглядаю, чи не були заарештовані знову мої колеги.
Якщо поліція не прийшла до мене до п’ятої ранку,
значить вона увірвалася до когось іншого.
Жінка зберегла почуття гумору, інакше її робота
була б нестерпною - зізнається Чошкун.
Адже її робоче місце там, де закінчується
свобода преси, - в Палаці Правосуддя
у Стамбулі.
Щодня мені здається, що ця будівля - величезний монстр,
який чекає на мене зі своїм потворним обличчям -
коли я увійду всередину.
Зйомка на камеру в суді заборонена,
тож ми продовжуємо приховано знімати на смартфон.
Сьогодні знову слухають справу щодо її колег
з щоденного видання Cumhuriyet.
Їх обвинувачують у розголошенні державної таємниці.
Окрім Чошкун, тут лише кілька журналістів.
Судові процеси проти працівників ЗМІ стали сумною рутиною
в Туреччині. Іноді суд перешкоджає
і їхній діяльності.
Вони кажуть, в залі немає місця для преси. Для таких
важливих процесів завжди обирають найменші кімнати.
Максимум у них можуть вміститися 20 людей.
Якось мені довелося висвітлювати судовий процес
і паралельно бігати до іншої кімнати, де судили мене.
Тоді журналістку
визнали невинною у перешкоджанні судовому процесу.
Коли журналісти або адвокати, як на цьому відео,
протестують проти робочих умов у Палаці Правосуддя,
їх виганяють із зали засідань. Юристи також
безсилі проти репресій в країні, каже Чошкун.
Наразі 150 журналістів сидять за ґратами
в Туреччині - такі дані правозахисних організацій.
На вулиці поліція знімає на відео журналістів
під час роботи. Чошкун знає, що одного дня
і вона може потрапити за ґрати. Нині троє
її колег у в’язниці, проти редакції
відкрито десятки судових справ.